[Music]
all right let's take another call let's
go to christopher in
butte montana christopher what's going
on
hi how are you doing today all right
brother how are you
i'm doing all right um thanks for taking
my call you got it man so what's up
okay well um just to probably make
something
brief that's a bit more than brief um
ever since i was a kid i'm 23 now
ever since i was a kid 12 14 um i've
always been
almost too good at talking to people and
that has since probably since i was 14
15 has almost made me a compulsive liar
um and it's
dug its nastiness into my marriage and i
don't really know well i know how to fix
it but i'm scared too
if that makes sense yeah absolutely and
i really just don't know what to do um
so that's why i'm calling well dude this
is hard and i've been there
i had the same challenge growing up and
um i watched a an executive
self-destruct with the same problem
and i had a ringside seat too oh this is
what how this ends
and it was almost like a light switch in
my life um and so i'm
grateful that at 23 you're able to
recognize this in yourself and want to
do something about it
um backing up men
why do you believe that this true story
of you christopher
is of less value than this concocted
story that you tell
um that's a deep question i feel like
um i feel like i'm a fairly smart person
and in a lot of circumstances i know
what the right thing or what i should be
doing is
and at the same time for some reason
maybe laziness maybe something along
those lines
i don't do what that right thing is but
i don't want to admit that
if that makes sense um so give me an
example
uh let's see
a really good example this is one of the
big ones that i'm trying to figure out
how to deal with
so my wife and i were going to school
right now online
and i'll be honest school has not been
my forte
um that we're college it's been really
rough
but i haven't figured out how to tell my
wife that
uh um she's a big believer in making
sure we have a degree
and we're doing fairly well i'm a store
manager
but uh regardless uh
i guess i'm scared to tell her that if
that makes sense but that's what and
that's what i'm told
i'm trying to get to the root here
there's a story that you've been told
and that over time you've adopted and
you tell yourself
that the things that you want to do in
your life
aren't valuable or aren't worth or
aren't
enough and so you create personas that
you are a little bit tougher a little
bit faster you hooked up with a few more
people you ran a little bit faster than
you actually did you scored a few more
points in this whatever the things are
and because at some deep
level the narrative that you've adopted
is
chris what christopher wants is not good
what christopher wants is less than and
so
you spend your life creating an alt
universe for everybody around you
yeah and then what happens when you're
living an alt universe
you start living multiple art alt
universes and the only thing that
tamps that down is addiction
and the only thing that tamps that down
is
stimulation somewhere else right and so
when you are
um i'll just use your example right you
can tell me if i'm out to lunch here
you don't like me in school you would
rather not be
you know that your wife really values it
so you miss a class and you miss another
class and then you
don't do super great on assignment and
then you don't tell her and now you got
a secret between you
you planted a seed and it's a secret and
then you've had that weird feeling when
she says how was school and
just you blurt out cool man going great
how's that test
it was good and now that secret you
watered it
right and now it's growing up between
you and then you feel that gap and that
distance and the only thing that makes
that gap in distance go away
it doesn't go away not burn a hole in
you is
pornography talking to somebody else at
work
that you can be flirty with another
drink another drink
just watching uh episodes after episodes
you start having to fill that gap with
something else because you've
you've created a a gap in the
relationship am i
am i onto something am i right yeah
okay if you are okay um not that i've
lived this but i'm just saying right
so here's what you've got to do there's
only one way through this and you know
what it is
right but it's it's you think you know
what it is but you actually don't it's
gonna be a little bit different
first and foremost you got to come clean
on
all of it and the story you just told me
about
school is the most sanitized one of
these things am i right
yeah okay what's the one giant
um thing that you're holding on to that
you haven't told her
um well i there's two okay
and one is sort of a root of all of this
but the first big one
is i it's school related i've
basically am on the verge of getting
kicked out
and the second one is pornography
related um
ding ding ding okay yeah and
did you cheat on her when y'all were
dating no
that is one lion i've never crossed
fortunately all right good
um all right so here's what we're gonna
do you're gonna um
have that conversation with him you're
going to let her know it's coming okay
and you're going to tell her hey we have
to talk about some hard things and so i
want you to clear your schedule
and um it's going to be a couple hours
and i've got some stuff i need to talk
to you about number one she's probably
gonna know more about this than you
think she does
occasionally people are totally
blindsided but often not
um and then number two before you have
that conversation
you've gotta get with a male friend of
yours
a guy friend and tell him everything
all of it and you have to commit
to somebody not your wife
that this is the last dishonest thing
you ever say and or do
period okay
the only way forward is um
to keep a sentence in mind that a a
mentor of mine gave
it told me his name is randy harris and
he said the greatest question anybody
can ever ask themselves is this
is integrity something you can sort of
have
is integrity something you can mostly
have
and i don't draw a lot of hard lines but
i do draw a hard line about that
because dishonesty and stealing destroys
people and if you just tell your
this to your wife you are too smart and
too quick
and you will wrap this up and she wants
so hard to believe in you
that she will buy whatever box of crap
you're trying to sell her
and you know that and i know that so
you've got to bring somebody else into
this conversation that's going to hold
you accountable it'd be really cool if
it was your dad
or if it was her dad or somebody of high
importance that you really want their
approval
you really want them to speak in your
life but my guess is
one or both of those men probably
contribute to this challenge that may
not be the best
if you've got a spiritual mentor that
you trust if you've got an older
wiser gentleman that you trust an old
college professor somebody that will
speak into your life and will call you
regularly
and say are you still telling the truth
right or that when you do slip up and
lie you can let them know how i screwed
up today
almost like an aaa meeting
now are you actually going to do that or
no no that actually sounds
like something i want to do
i don't know really how to explain it
but and i mean maybe you
have heard this or can understand it but
it just it's a lot to
yes it's like i'm always worrying about
it you know yes
it's weird i've never talked about this
out loud so this is a
lot yes it it's a ton right and you will
um you'll feel better after this call
you'll feel better after this call you
will know um
because here's the thing you're carrying
around a sack full of bricks man all the
lies but beneath the lies
is this narrative that what i want and
what i value
doesn't matter and so i've got to keep
everybody around me happy and the way i
keep them happy is by
giving them all stories different
versions of myself
you got to stop today
i will never lie i'll never steal again
and when i
slip up on one of those i'm gonna go to
the ends of the earth to make it right
to call it out
to be over the top about it okay i
appreciate your bravery christopher
today's the day here's what i want you
to do i want you to um
make that declaration today call
somebody today talk to him about it and
then
let your wife know we're going to meet
this weekend we need to have some direct
conversations
and by the way don't flunk out of school
don't flunk out of school there's no
professor on earth that wants to flunk
you out of school
that's you deciding i'm going to make a
statement don't do that
at the very least go to your professors
and say hey i need to take a
incomplete i need to talk about this i
haven't been doing my work
but don't choose to flunk out of school
man um that's choosing to take one of
those bricks out of your backpack and
just hit yourself in the head with it
that's that's a waste of time
all right so you're on it down you're on
the america's clock
the dishonesty stops today
right all right everybody we'll be right
back stay tuned on the dr john dolone
show
[Music]